we who are you we're the avengers man
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie these are
gonna be my venom spider-man marvel
Easter eggs hopefully you've had a
chance to see the movie but obviously
careful for spoilers if you have not yet
because we're talking about very
specific stuff there's a new round of
that spider-man ps4 a game giveaway -
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a venom related
comments on the video certainly with a
big stuff first you probably noticed
that the astronaut that was flying that
spacecraft that crashed with the
symbiote was named Jameson that's the
son of Jay jonah Jameson himself he
debuted in the very first amazing
spider-man title spider-man had to save
a crashing spaceship they also did the
90s animated TV series venom origin
story where Jay jonah Jameson's son is
flying a space shuttle they get an alien
soil sample that just happens to have
the symbiote in and then when they try
to land the spaceship it crashes in New
York City because the symbiote breaks
containment it possesses Jay jonah
Jameson's son what's happening
when any tries to expose Carlton Drake
but then gets fired that's actually a
reference to him getting fired in the
comics for fake news there was a Sin
Eater article that he tried to expose
spider-man caught the real Sin Eater
and then exposed Eddie as a fraud so
part of the reason why he's called venom
is is because when he was calling other
people there was a montage during the
movie when he was trying to find work in
the comics he did the same thing but the
excuses that other people were giving
for not hiring him were that he was
venomous that was Todd McFarlane's way
of explaining how you got to the venom
name in the comics why Eddie would call
himself venom because everyone else
thought that he was venomous the
newspaper that he got fired from in New
York City they say was the Daily Globe
but the Daily Globe is from amazing
spider-man number 27 so it is a thing
from the comics you probably heard the
law firm shout out the law firm that an
Wayne gets fired from after the whole
Eddie incident is Micheline in
MacFarlane the two people that created
the venom character David Michelin and
Todd McFarlane the name of Eddie's
apartment is also a really big deep cut
it's named the Shuler building after
Randy Schuler who submitted the idea for
the black symbiote costume way back
during Secret Wars when Jim shooter was
taking fan ideas so he submitted the
idea for spider-man wearing a costume
that looked like this it had a red
emblem Marvel decided to change that
gave him the white emblem but he's
essentially the guy who was the reason
for the way the costume looks the way it
does now his idea didn't have anything
to do with it being a symbiote in it
being alive that came with Todd
McFarlane and much much later when they
turned it into something of an evil
antihero type character when they
introduced it to the Eddie Brock
character but there's also a building
named after Ron Lim who's the penciler
who took over on artwork for the venom
solo title when he got his first little
mini-series they almost did all five of
the symbiotes from a lethal protector
but there were only four total including
the venom one so after to the riot
symbiote leaves Jay jonah Jameson and
enters that female EMT and she just
walks off into the night that's actually
Dona Diego from the comics she got the
scream symbiote the yellow one and there
was a yellow symbiote although the one
that she had was the riot one at the
time the other symbiotes that they did
from the Lisa
Tector story line with a bluish looking
one which was agony in the green looking
one which was Lasher they wound up dying
during experimentation which is why they
were only left with the venom in the
riot symbiotes at the end of the
motorcycle chase when venom picks that
security guard up and says that he's
going to eat him so many snacks so
little time that's actually right out of
the first appearance of venom after he
goes after Peter Parker when he starts
getting all crazy about eating brains
though that's actually from venom the
hunger comic book title so that didn't
come till later when the movie reveals
that some of the symbiotes are eating
their hosts alive even the Venom
symbiote starts to eat eddie a little
bit and then says quickly that i can fix
him that's actually right out of the
comics too when spider-man
first wanted to get rid of the black
costume when he found out that it was
alive he found out that it was literally
eating him alive the original comic book
origin of Eddie Brock venom was a bit of
a retcon to that actual story so
spider-man uses the sonic frequencies to
get rid of the symbiote then later when
Todd McFarlane came on the title they
sort of added a little addendum to what
happened after spider-man used the bells
to get the costume up in the original
version of the story the symbiote just
slinked off into the night then later
Todd McFarlane retcon that so that the
symbiote fell to Eddie Brock and he just
happened to be in the area when this was
happening when the symbiote bonds with
an Wang so that they can go save Eddie
that's a reference to Shi venom which is
a thing from the comics where an Wang
did get the symbiote then the actual
grand plan that riot has to take the
shuttle into orbit and bring all of the
other symbiotes down to Planet Earth is
a comic book reference to Planet of the
symbiotes the whole idea that the
symbiotes are evil and want to consume
planet Earth is actually something
that's been retcon more recently so
symbiotes used to be a little bit more
terrible in the very recent comics you
meet the god of the symbiotes who
actually created the all-black which is
the necro sword used during the Thor
comics which is a big Thor Easter egg
that then becomes shards of the Gods
soul those are the symbiotes I did a
video a little while ago they actually
use that for the tale of Beowulf so Thor
was part of Marvel's version of the
Beowulf origin story but it turns out
that Grendel really was a symbiote in
that
version of events obviously I mentioned
lethal protector The Life Foundation
Carlton Drake both characters right out
of that the whole idea is is one of the
earliest stories where venom gets to be
more heroic than he would normally be so
the sort of turn venom into an antihero
but that really didn't happen till after
a carnage was introduced in the comic
book version the difference is is that
Carlton Drake already had Eddie Brock
with the symbiote he forces it to
reproduce creating five new children of
venom not including carnage during the
final big boss battle when he's fighting
the riot symbiote it says this guy has
things that you've never seen before
that's a reference to carnage he starts
making blades all kinds of projectiles
that extend from his body those are all
skills that they didn't really introduce
til the carnage symbiote came along and
when they're ripping each other apart
and you see their human faces beneath
the symbiotes here that's actually a
panel right out of the 1995 venom
carnage Unleashed miniseries where
carnage is ripping the symbiote right
off of Eddie's head it was a very
notable Wilhelm scream when he was
attacking those security guards they put
it in all the trailers can't really get
away with the big John Woo film without
a Wilhelm scream in there somewhere then
there was obviously that huge carnage
post-credit scene which is an easter egg
for them introducing him in the comics
with his comic book origin just happens
to be there in proximity to Eddie Brock
when his symbiote spawns giving him his
own symbiote becoming the carnage
character but the graffiti that he's
using his own blood for while he's being
interviewed by Eddie is actually an
easter egg for this because after he
broke out in the comics he went on this
rampage spider-man went to investigate
and sure enough he signed his own work
there were a whole bunch of smaller
Easter eggs - like when the dog gets the
symbiote they've actually done that in
the comics before but let me know if he
spotted any really big ones that I
didn't mention in the video what'll
happen is this I'll do more venom and
carnage videos through the rest of the
years we learned more about what's going
on with the sequel obviously spider-man
into the spider verse is going to be
released in December there'll be more
footage for that dropping soon - but the
Russos dropped the most epic of teasers
last night saying that they had wrapped
officially on the reshoots for Avengers
4 so even though there is still a lot of
post production and special effects
editing left to be done on the film they
are officially done shooting new scenes
there been a lot of requested
a video for the supposed description of
the trailer so we'll probably do a video
for that either today or tomorrow and
just incorporate this new Rousseau's
little picture that they draw
congratulations Ezekiel Rodriguez you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
so no worries while you wait for
everything click here for that video of
the brand-new spider-man suit spotted in
New York City which is awesome and click
here for that new Avengers 4 armored
teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]